- Well, you've got something
else to look forward to.
So I hear next year it's Walk of Fame.
You're getting your Walk of Fame,
your star?
- Yes.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
- That's so cool.
- You had yours.
- I literally just had, I just did mine.
And you know what, I'm gonna tell you
the weirdest thing about it.
It's awesome. All of it is awesome.
But I have never, in 20 years,
had everyone from every part
of my career under one
umbrella, like one tent,
for one thing.
It's the first time that's ever happened.
So you're gonna look out and see people-
- That sounds very stressful.
- You know what, it wasn't.
- It wasn't?
- No. I tend to not keep
those people around.
- That's smart. That's smart.
- Yeah.
- I just am like, so I,
first of all, I don't know who to invite.
I'm like, am I gonna
fill the number of seats?
'Cause I'm like kind of a homebody.
Second of all, like, there's
so much, there's like,
do you put your hands in the,
is that just a-
- That's Grauman's.
That's Grauman's where they do the,
that's a different thing.
It's right there, like,
where the stars are.
But it's a, I learned this.
- Wait, there's two different ways-
- Exactly.
- That we commemorate famous people?
- Exactly. We come up with them.
I didn't know this either.
And so whenever it was
happening I was like,
"Do I have to do my hands or something?"
They're like, "No, it's Grauman's."
- Wait, I'm here getting all like,
excited to do that photo where I'm on-
- Well, you do the photo where you're on
the ground with the star.
Which try and look attractive
in that environment.
(Mindy laughs)
(audience laughs)
I literally saw the
pictures and I was like,
I guess approve.
Like, they're horrible.
But like, it's just like the most awkward-
- You have to lay down
sideways on the dirty street.
- Yeah. It's not great.
That look isn't great, but
I'm sure you'll pull it off.
I didn't and I just leaned into humor.
But will your "Office" co-stars be there?
Will people that you've been
working with, are you gonna-
- I'll invite them. I'll invite
them. They're pretty busy.
I think there's a couple
that'll definitely,
definitely come.
I think it'll be fun.
I'm one of these people,
I don't like to ever,
I mean I try to, but I have
trouble reflecting on success
'cause I'm superstitious and
I feel like if you spend too
much time thinking about
like, oh, you did a great job
or you should commemorate this,
that something bad is gonna happen.
It's like, I don't know. I'm
just like, one of those people.
So sometimes big life milestones,
like I didn't do a baby shower,
I didn't do any of that
stuff 'cause I was like,
I don't wanna jinx something.
I've just always been this way.
- [Kelly] Oh, I'm so opposite of you.
- Well, listen, that's
the healthy way to be.
- I didn't actually want a baby shower
because I hated pregnancy
and I just wanted
all humans to get away from me.
But like, but most times I think it's,
I think try and think of it though,
it's also kind of cool to go,
I think because in my career,
I don't know if you feel the same,
you forget things that happen.
- Yeah.
- Like you forget because you
didn't take the time to have that moment.
You didn't take the time to have that-
- To commemorate it.
- Commemorate it, yeah.
Yeah. So I don't know.
But what the hell do I know?
- To my kids, I can be like,
"See, I'm like a big deal.
Don't give me any crap."
- No, I'm telling you my six
and eight year old were
there and they were like,
they literally leaned over
to my mom and my sister,
I can't remember which one
it was, and they were like,
"Why is everybody like
yelling, like for my mom?"
They were like, they just
thought it was so weird.
So it's kind of cool to see.
You're like, yeah, mommy works hard.
I was like, it's kind nice
to be like, "That's right."
- No, it's true.
- [Kelly] It's nice.